Gloire à Dieu.
Donc nous continuons dans le cours des diacres.
La semaine dernière, on a parlé, pour ceux qui se souviennent,
on a un peu parlé du rôle des diacres,
on a parlé aussi des diacres dans la façon dont on peut administrer l'église aujourd'hui,
le rôle que les diacres peuvent avoir dans nos églises aujourd'hui.
Mais ce qui est toujours important pour nous,
c'est de toujours non partir de nous pour comprendre les choses que Dieu nous donne,
mais de partir de Dieu et après que ces choses arrivent jusqu'à nous.
Donc voilà pourquoi aussi ce soir, nous allons partir un peu sur la genèse des diacres.
Nous allons partir pour comprendre pourquoi il y a eu les diacres,
pourquoi ce rôle, le rôle stratégique qu'ils peuvent avoir dans l'église
et partir selon le modèle que Dieu nous a donné là-dessus.
Et pour faire un lien aussi avec, en intro aussi,
pour faire un lien avec ce qui nous a été enseigné vendredi dernier,
il y a eu une emphase qui a été beaucoup mise sur le rôle des anciens,
si vous vous souvenez.
Il y a eu un rappel de la tâche des anciens,
avant même d'aborder ce rôle des diacres.
Et c'est la genèse aussi des diacres que nous pouvons voir là,
parce que si vous vous souvenez de la parole à un moment,
Paul va dire à un moment que celui qui désire la tâche d'évêque désire une œuvre excellente.
On va dire que ça, c'est le côté, la façade,
le bon côté de la façade.
Donc on doit reconnaître que c'est une œuvre excellente,
mais c'est une œuvre qui est aussi très éprouvante.
Quand on regarde au niveau du ministère pastoral,
rien que pour vous dire, je regardais aussi dernièrement un article de Gospel Coalition
qui soulignait par exemple un taux assez élevé de pasteurs qui étaient en dépression à un moment.
Des pasteurs qui étaient fatigués après plusieurs années de service
et qui n'aspiraient par exemple qu'à avoir une année sabbatique,
de pouvoir souffler autre.
Et donc par rapport à ça, on reconnaît que c'est une œuvre excellente,
mais on reconnaît aussi que c'est une œuvre où il y a souvent beaucoup de fatigue,
il y a beaucoup de pression, il n'y a souvent pas de limites.
Souvent dans le ministère pastoral,
on va souvent avoir tendance à un peu enlever la barrière, les limites, la frontière.
Le pasteur n'est même pas censé avoir une certaine intimité.
Le pasteur doit toujours être disponible pour toutes les requêtes.
Il doit être disponible à n'importe quel moment,
il doit être disponible pour n'importe quelle doléance qu'on aurait.
Et on va voir aussi que ce que Dieu nous montre aussi,
c'est que pour pallier et pour mieux aider les pasteurs dans cette tâche pastorale,
on voit aussi la genèse des diacres.
Et je vais demander, je ne sais pas, Jordi, c'est notre expert de lecture.
Si Jordi, tu peux, s'il te plaît, nous lire.
Tu prépares acte 6 du verset 1 au verset 7.
Mais une chose donc aussi là-dessus, c'est cette importance de voir
qu'au début, on peut trouver beaucoup de joie,
mais à un moment, on va comprendre à un moment que les choses ne sont pas toujours évidentes.
et de nous souvenir aussi de ces paroles de Pierre,
de la peau de Pierre quand il va rappeler,
ces paroles dans Hébreu, quand il nous a aussi rappelé d'avoir de la déférence
pour ceux qui nous enseignent, de prendre soin aussi des anciens dans ce sens-là aussi.
Tu as trouvé, si tu peux nous lire, acte 6.
Donc, ce sera le passage sur lequel nous allons nous plonger ce soir.
Ce sera le passage de référence pour tout ce qui sera partagé.
Acte 6 du verset 1 au verset 7.
En ce temps-là, le nombre des disciples augmentant,
les élimites de numérés contre les hébreux,
par que leur vœu était négligé par la distribution qui se faisait chaque jour.
Les douze convocèrent la multitude des disciples et dirent,
« Il n'est pas convenable que nous laissions la parole de Dieu pour servir aux tables.
C'est pourquoi, frères, choisissez parmi nous sept hommes
de qui l'ont rend un bon témoignage,
qu'il soit plein d'esprit saint et de sagesse,
et que nous chargerons de cet emploi.
Et nous, nous continuerons à nous appliquer à la prière et au ministère de la parole. »
Cette proposition put à tous l'attendu.
Ils déduirent Étienne, homme plein de foi et d'esprit saint,
Philippe, Rochor, Mikanor, Timon, Parméas et Nicolas,
aux élites d'antir.
Ils les présentèrent aux apôtres,
qui, après avoir prié, leur s'imposèrent à l'humain.
La parole de Dieu se répandait de plus en plus.
Le nombre des disciples augmentait beaucoup à Jérusalem,
et une grande foule des sacrificateurs obéitait à la parole.
Amen.
Merci.
Donc ça, ce sera le texte principal.
Mais en finissant aussi l'introduction, pour rentrer dans ce texte,
nous voyons aussi que depuis un certain temps,
souvent on met beaucoup d'enfants sur l'Église primitive.
On va voir les bons côtés de l'Église primitive à un moment.
D'ailleurs, on a lu encore un passage tout à l'heure,
pendant que nous étions en train de prier,
qui nous rappelait aussi la beauté de ce que Dieu faisait
dans l'Église primitive au tout début.
Et c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à se focaliser sur ça.
Mais ce qu'on va remarquer,
lorsqu'on a tendance à se focaliser sur ça,
c'est que dans ce que nous avons lu dans Acte 6,
on va remarquer aussi qu'avec la croissance,
il y a, comme le dit le passage,
il y a des tensions qui vont surgir.
Avec la croissance, il y a des tensions qui vont surgir.
Et le problème, c'est que là où l'Église était en train de croître
en bonne santé, qu'on voyait des miracles par les apôtres,
on nous dit même que tous ceux qui croyaient étaient dans le même lieu,
ils avaient tout en commun, toutes ces belles choses.
On va voir un moment où on va être confronté au fait
qu'avec le fait de la croissance, l'Église va rencontrer un problème.
Donc c'est ce passage tout à l'heure que notre frère Jordi nous a lu.
Et dans ce passage,
on voit, et c'est tout à fait normal,
parce que nous devons aussi être conscients de ça,
je me souviens encore que, et je peux le réaliser aujourd'hui,
qu'avoir une Église où il n'y a que 10 personnes,
c'est totalement différent d'avoir une Église
où il y a une centaine,
une centaine de personnes.
Donc là, il y a un problème qui va se poser
avec la croissance,
il va y avoir une organisation de l'Église
pour prendre soin des plus démunis,
et là, dans ce cadre, c'était aussi les veuves
pour la répartition des repas.
Mais il va y avoir un problème,
c'est que les Juifs hélénistes,
et on reviendra aussi là-dessus sur la signification,
les Juifs hélénistes vont trouver un moment
que leurs veuves ne sont pas bien,
on ne prend pas bien soin de leurs veuves
pour la destruction des repas,
donc ils vont se plaindre.
Et dans cette plainte,
on peut voir que c'est déjà des problèmes
qui sont...
On voit l'Église qui est déjà dans une série de problèmes.
Ce que nous voyons aussi,
c'est qu'il y a des attaques,
on doit être conscient aussi
qu'avec la croissance que l'Église était en train d'avoir,
l'Église aussi était en train d'être attaquée.
Il y a un livre de John Stott,
là, je n'ai pas la référence,
mais il va nous parler un moment
qu'on voit plusieurs types d'attaques,
qui pouvaient arriver par rapport à ça.
Mais la première chose,
je vais me référer au texte,
ça va plutôt m'aider aussi.
Donc, le verset 7 va nous dire un moment,
« La parole de Dieu se répondait toujours plus,
le nombre des disciples s'accroissait beaucoup à Jérusalem. »
Donc, la conclusion qu'on nous montre ici,
ce n'est pas la conclusion qui a failli arriver.
Ce qu'on nous sommes en train de réaliser,
c'est que la situation aurait pu être bien pire.
C'est-à-dire que par rapport à ce qui s'est posé,
si les apôtres n'avaient pas su prendre les bonnes décisions
et n'avaient pas su régler le problème,
aujourd'hui, peut-être que nous ne serions pas en train de lire
ce que nous sommes en train de lire.
Peut-être que même la conclusion du verset 7,
ce ne serait pas la conclusion du verset 7 que nous aurions.
Mais nous avons la conclusion du verset 7
parce que du verset 2 au verset 6,
nous voyons ce qui a été fait pour la résolution de ce problème.
Et on nous parle de l'élection des 7.
Donc là, quand nous lisons ce texte,
nulle part dans ce texte,
quand vous lisez Acte, chapitre 6,
vous allez trouver quelque part qu'on nous parle du terme de diacre.
On ne nous parle pas,
vous n'allez pas lire le terme de diacre en tant que tel.
Mais ce que nous voyons dans ce texte,
c'est que c'est un texte qui va poser les bases.
On va dire que les 7 qui vont être élus pour aider les apôtres,
ces 7-là, on peut dire que ce sont des précurseurs.
Ils vont poser les bases.
Plus tard, dans ce que Paul va donner,
lorsque Paul va donner, par exemple, le texte à Timothée,
il va donner les recommandations à Timothée
dans le choix des diacres,
on peut aussi penser que cet exemple,
cette base qui a été donnée avec le choix des 7,
a aussi pu permettre à l'Église après de savoir
comment on va partir pour un peu plus instituer les diacres.
Et par contre, ce qui est intéressant aussi,
c'est que dans ce texte, on peut justement tirer des leçons.
Il y a des leçons aussi, on va revenir là-dessus.
Il y a des leçons qu'on peut tirer aussi
pour comprendre justement le rôle des diacres par rapport à ça.
Et je voulais aussi, parce que nous sommes dans cette formation,
nous sommes aussi dans la formation des diacres,
dans la formation des anciens.
Certains qui sont ici aussi sont en train de réfléchir
à cet appel d'anciens, à cet appel des diacres.
Et il y a aussi des leçons très importantes à tirer de ça.
Donc, lorsque cette situation arrive,
que les hélénistes viennent vers les apôtres et se plaignent,
on va déjà voir la façon dont les apôtres ont eu à gérer le problème.
Les apôtres auraient peut-être pu se fâcher,
parce que quand nous sommes dans un texte comme celui-là,
où nous sommes en train de lire un moment que
tous ceux qui croyaient étaient dans le même lieu,
ils avaient tout en commun, ils vendaient leurs propriétés,
ils ont partagé le produit.
Ils étaient chaque jour ensemble assidus au temple,
ils rampaient le pain et prenaient leur nourriture
avec joie et simplicité de cœur, louant Dieu
et trouvant grâce auprès de tout le peuple.
Et le Seigneur a ajouté chaque jour à l'Église,
ceux qui étaient sauvés.
Quand nous voyons ça, nous pouvons nous dire que
par rapport à tout ce qui est en train d'être fait,
par rapport à toute cette beauté,
les apôtres auraient pu peut-être
réprimander les frères qui étaient en train de se plaindre.
Ils auraient même pu s'emporter,
même avoir une colère légitime,
parce qu'au lieu de se focaliser,
au lieu de voir ce qui est en train de marcher,
eux, ils étaient en train de se focaliser
sur un petit problème de distribution de nourriture.
On aurait pu voir qu'à un moment,
ils auraient pu se fâcher sur ça,
mais c'est intéressant de voir que les apôtres
n'ont pas eu ces réactions-là.
Ils n'ont pas eu cette réaction de s'emporter,
de se mettre en colère, de menacer.
Et ça rappelle, je vais prendre parce que je voulais aussi,
1 Pierre 5, verset 3.
1 Pierre 5, verset 3, nous dit,
« N'exercez pas un pouvoir... »
Donc, il parle des pasteurs.
« Comme des bergers, à partir même du verset 2,
comme des bergers, prenez soin du troupeau de Dieu
qui vous a été confié.
Veillez sur lui, non comme si vous y étiez forcé,
mais de plein gré, ainsi que Dieu le désire.
Faites-le, non pour un profit matériel,
mais par dévouement.
N'exercez pas un pouvoir autoritaire
sur ceux qui ont été confiés à vos soins,
mais soyez les modèles du troupeau. »
Donc, dans cette situation,
on va voir un moment que les apôtres
qui auraient pu s'emporter
à cause du problème qui est en train d'être posé
vont beaucoup plus agir avec douceur,
avec patience, avec sagesse.
Ils ne vont pas négliger, ils ne vont pas dire
qu'on a des priorités plus importantes,
on a des choses plus importantes à régler
et vous nous apportez un problème aussi mineur.
Non.
Ils vont, au contraire, avec beaucoup de sagesse,
ils vont même, et même là,
la décision qu'ils donnent,
en disant un moment,
ils disent,
« C'est pourquoi, frère,
choisissez parmi vous cet homme réputé,
digne de confiance. »
Ce qu'ils sont en train de faire,
ils sont en train de dire que,
même par rapport à la tâche que nous avons déjà,
si on se met à s'occuper de cette tâche,
il se peut même que ce problème,
on ne le traite pas bien.
Ce qu'on va faire,
vu que nous devons nous plonger pleinement
dans le ministère de la parole et de la prière,
nous allons vous recommander,
choisissez cette personne digne de confiance
et ces personnes vont régler le problème.
Et donc, on voit que les apôtres,
au lieu de s'emporter,
vont plutôt convoquer l'Assemblée,
ils vont convoquer l'Assemblée
et ils vont exprimer à l'Assemblée
cette décision-là.
Et donc, qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ?
Ils disent,
« Il ne serait pas légitime
que nous arrêtions de proclamer la parole de Dieu
pour nous occuper des distributions.
C'est pourquoi, frère,
choisissez parmi vous cet homme réputé,
digne de confiance,
rempli du Saint-Esprit et de sagesse.
Nous les chargerons de ce travail.
Cela nous permettra de nous consacrer
à la prière et au service de l'enseignement. »
Donc, à partir de ce point,
on voit qu'il y a quatre points
qui vont caractériser les sept personnes
qu'ils vont choisir.
Donc, nous ne voyons pas encore
que la Bible nous parle des diacres en tant que tels,
mais nous voyons déjà que même bien plus tard,
ce rôle de diacre,
au travers des points qu'on va ressortir,
c'est ce rôle de diacre qui va même être,
ils vont poser les bases pour ce rôle de diacre.
Donc, le premier point qui est donné
dans cette réflexion des apôtres,
ce sera la priorité qui doit être donnée
au ministère de la parole.
Si nous lisons, en lisant Actes,
on va remarquer que l'Église est en train de grandir,
l'Église est en train d'avoir une croissance,
le Saint-Esprit est en train de fortifier les frères,
mais nous allons déjà trouver des événements
qui sont...
Satan ne dort pas.
Et Satan va créer plusieurs événements
pour affaiblir l'Église,
pour détruire l'Église.
Je dis même affaiblir,
le mot est trop simple,
pour détruire l'Église.
Donc, au chapitre 4,
on va par exemple voir un moment
qu'il y a une persécution extérieure
qui va venir pour essayer de détruire l'Église.
La persécution ne va rien faire.
Au chapitre 5,
on va voir un moment
qu'il y a la corruption avec Ananias et Saphira,
où il y a une corruption morale
qui peut être apportée au sein de l'Église.
Mais là encore,
le Saint-Esprit va conduire les apôtres
à avoir de la sagesse.
Ananias et Saphira vont être condamnés.
Ça va créer la crainte de Dieu.
Et là, maintenant,
on voit que comme Satan a échoué
dans ces choses qui étaient beaucoup plus frontales,
il va utiliser quelque chose
de beaucoup plus subtil.
Donc, ils vont venir,
certains frères vont venir se plaindre
qu'il y avait des problèmes au niveau du repas.
Et maintenant,
Satan va essayer de créer la distraction.
Donc, David nous a déjà parlé de ça
lors de l'introduction au cours des membres.
Il nous a parlé de cette distraction
où Satan va essayer d'éloigner les apôtres
de leur tâche principale.
Eux qui étaient censés être pleinement consacrés
au ministère de la parole et de la prière,
Satan va essayer de créer un problème
pour qu'il soit détourné, qu'il soit distrait
et qu'il soit peut-être sur autre chose.
Mais nous voyons que les apôtres vont bien rappeler
le rôle qu'il leur est échu.
Ils vont bien rappeler que leur axe principal de travail,
c'est de se concentrer sur la parole
et le soin de l'Église sur beaucoup plus le plan spirituel.
Et ce qu'ils sont en train de dire,
c'est qu'on peut avoir, lorsqu'on est en train de lire ça,
on peut se dire un moment, mais qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent dire ?
Ils veulent dire que le fait de s'occuper de ce problème,
ce n'est pas un problème plus important,
que eux, ils sont peut-être trop importants spirituellement
pour s'occuper d'un tel problème.
Non, ce qu'ils étaient en train de montrer,
et c'est aussi une leçon pour nous aujourd'hui dans nos Églises,
c'était la priorité de la parole et de la prière.
Ce qu'ils étaient en train de montrer à un moment,
c'est que l'Église peut agir pour aider sur un plan social,
mais ce n'est pas la mission première de l'Église.
La mission première de l'Église,
et là, nous le rappelons encore par rapport à la génération
où nous sommes aujourd'hui,
où à un moment, dans beaucoup d'Églises,
on a finalement beaucoup importé le social,
les combats sociaux, raciaux dans l'Église.
L'Église n'est pas appelée à ça.
L'Église est appelée au ministère de la parole et de la prière,
l'Église est appelée à l'évangélisation.
Donc, les apôtres ne sont pas en train de dire
qu'ils sont en train de négliger cette tâche.
D'ailleurs, voilà pourquoi ils vont même demander,
vous voyez, même dans les qualifications,
ils auraient pu dire, choisissez cette personne.
Non, ils vont donner les recommandations
pour le choix de ces personnes,
parce qu'ils prennent soin de cela.
mais ils sont en train de dire, nous, nous avons une priorité,
nous ne pouvons pas nous détourner de cette priorité-là.
Et la vérité que nous avons aussi là-derrière,
c'est que vous voyez, aujourd'hui,
nous sommes dans une Église
où nous n'avons pas de diacre officiellement.
Mais ça ne nous empêche pas d'avancer.
Mais si vous avez une Église
où la parole n'est pas prichée,
ça, c'est quelque chose d'autre.
Si vous avez une Église
où les gens ne sont pas suffisamment nourris,
ça, c'est quelque chose d'autre.
Dans notre jeunesse,
en apprenant les choses,
je me souviens, au début de l'Église Bonne Nouvelle,
David n'était pas encore le pasteur principal.
À un moment, il y a eu une recommandation
pour qu'on ait davantage de communion fraternelle.
Et donc, la proposition, c'était,
comme on était au théâtre du gymnase,
on avait la possibilité d'avoir l'endroit
où il y avait le restaurant.
Donc, on a un moment proposé
qu'on fasse des cultes en haut.
et le pasteur principal a donc accepté
à un moment qu'on fasse des cultes de communion
et il n'y avait pas de prédication.
Donc, à un moment, c'était un culte
où il fallait juste qu'on ait de la communion,
mais sans prédication.
Et on a fait,
quand on a commencé ce culte,
en fait, on s'est rendu compte
que les gens ne venaient plus.
On avait voulu faire un culte
pour encourager la communion,
mais les gens ressentaient le besoin
d'écouter la parole,
donc ils allaient dans d'autres églises
pour ce dimanche-là
et ils revenaient lorsqu'on a recommencé.
Et ça a été une leçon
pour nous faire comprendre
l'importance du fait
qu'on ne peut pas déroger à ça.
On peut donc, à un moment,
ne pas avoir certaines activités
dans l'église,
mais on ne peut pas se passer
du fait qu'il y ait
l'enseignement de la parole,
on ne peut pas se passer
du fait qu'il y ait la prière.
Et donc, les apôtres sont en train
de rappeler l'importance de tout cela.
Donc, ça, c'était le premier point.
Le premier point qui va concerner,
à un moment,
lorsqu'on va parler du choix
des sept qui sont choisis
par les apôtres,
on va voir un moment,
donc, ce qui est là,
c'est que les apôtres vont parler
de la priorité qui est donnée
au fait du ministère de la parole.
Le deuxième point,
c'est aussi de montrer
l'implication de l'Assemblée.
Et ça aussi, encore,
voilà pourquoi ce texte aussi
est un texte très important
pour nous faire comprendre
l'importance aussi
de l'église en tant que corps.
Ce qui se passe à un moment,
c'est que les apôtres
n'ont pas choisi unilatéralement
les sept.
Ils ne sont pas dit à un moment,
on va s'asseoir,
on choisit ces sept personnes
et puis,
ils vont accepter notre décision.
Non.
Nous voyons bien à un moment
que les apôtres vont
convoquer l'Assemblée
et ils vont leur expliquer
un moment,
verset 2,
alors les douze apôtres
réunirent l'ensemble des disciples.
Alors les douze apôtres
réunirent l'ensemble des disciples
et leur dire,
et donc les apôtres
réunissent tout le monde
et ils décident
parce que ce qu'ils vont
faire comprendre,
c'est que,
vous voyez,
même dans le groupe
de l'ensemble
de ces disciples,
beaucoup étaient
des nouveaux convertis.
Si on compte
ceux qui étaient
réellement affirmés,
qui avaient le Christ,
c'était une poignée.
Il y avait beaucoup
qui avaient été rajoutés
avec l'évangélisation,
ce qui s'était passé
à la Pentecôte.
Et donc là,
l'église était à peu près
entre 3 000
et 8 000 membres.
Là,
l'église comptait
à peu près 8 000 membres.
Mais ce qui va se passer,
c'est qu'ils vont quand même
convoquer l'ensemble.
Même ceux
qu'on va dire peut-être,
ce sont peut-être
des bébés spirituels,
ils n'ont pas besoin
de prendre part à ça.
Non,
toute l'église est convoquée.
Et pourquoi toute l'église
est convoquée ?
Parce que le premier point,
c'est que tous étaient
des croyants.
Tous étaient des croyants.
Et même si c'était un problème
qui ne concernait
qu'une minorité,
c'est un problème
qui concernait
l'ensemble du corps.
Et donc,
le premier point,
c'est que tous étaient croyants.
Le deuxième point aussi,
c'est qu'à un moment,
comme ça les concernait tous,
il était nécessaire.
Et voilà pourquoi on parle
aussi de cet aspect
congrégationnel.
Il était nécessaire
que pour une solution
qui ne touchait
qu'une infime partie,
l'ensemble soit convoquée
pour cela.
Et voilà pourquoi,
par exemple,
et on vous rappelle aussi
l'importance de l'AG.
Voilà pourquoi,
lorsqu'on parle de l'AG,
quand on donne une date
pour l'AG,
si vous avez vraiment
un empêchement
de dernière minute,
on peut le comprendre.
Mais la recommandation,
c'est que nous tous,
nous soyons là
à l'Assemblée générale.
Pour tous ceux
qui sont des membres
de l'église.
Parce que c'est là aussi
où, par rapport
à certains problèmes,
certaines décisions,
justement aussi,
ces choses vous sont rapportées
et c'est ensemble aussi
que nous sommes en train
de valider des décisions.
Voilà dans ce sens aussi
ce que Dieu donne là-dessus.
Et ce qu'il donne aussi
encore comme modèle,
c'est dans le choix
des diacres.
Donc, je vous dis à un moment
que ça n'a pas été
un choix unilatéral
des apôtres.
Ce qu'ils ont fait,
ils vont dire
« C'est pourquoi, frères,
choisissez parmi vous
cet homme réputé,
digne de confiance,
rempli de Saint-Esprit
et de sagesse.
Choisissez cet homme. »
Donc, ce qui a été donné,
c'est que l'église
devait voir,
l'église devait voir
ceux qui pouvaient
être dignes de confiance.
Elle voyait la vie
de ceux qui servent,
de ceux qui sont capables
de pouvoir porter
cette charge.
L'église reconnaît
cela en eux
et c'est ce que nous parlons
quand nous parlons
d'un des aspects
de la reconnaissance
des diacres.
La reconnaissance des diacres
ne se fait pas
parce que c'est celui
qui gère mieux
le budget de l'église,
son propre budget
ou bien c'est celui
qui est le plus riche.
Vous voyez,
la semaine dernière,
nous avons parlé aujourd'hui
de comment certaines églises
vont choisir les diacres.
On va choisir
parce que c'est lui
qui pourvoit à peu près
à l'ensemble de l'argent
pour que l'église tourne.
Donc, on le nomme diacre.
On a pris plusieurs caractéristiques.
Si vous vous souvenez,
il y a eu plusieurs,
on a pris plusieurs exemples
de diacres.
Mais là, nous voyons
le modèle biblique.
Le modèle biblique,
c'était un choix d'ensemble.
C'est-à-dire que les anciens
vont dire à un moment,
choisissez,
voyez parmi vous
ceux qui sont dignes
de cette tâche.
Et quand vous avez vu
les personnes
qui sont dignes
de cette tâche aussi,
les apôtres aussi
vont valider aussi
pour reconnaître aussi
ces choses-là.
Et quand on a vu...
Donc, je peux dire aujourd'hui,
à Bonne Nouvelle,
on a à peu près aussi
cette démarche-là.
Il y a une démarche
qui est présentée
dans le livre de Nine Marks,
vous verrez,
mais cette même démarche aussi,
nous l'avons aussi
à Bonne Nouvelle,
où l'encouragement
dans le choix des diacres
va être aussi
de voir l'église valide,
le choix des diacres.
On va voir des personnes
qui peuvent être dignes
de cette tâche
et c'est l'ensemble
de l'église
qui va valider.
Donc, à un moment,
pour ceux qui sont
membres de l'église,
dans les choix,
à un moment,
de certaines décisions,
vous allez voir,
même, je me souviens,
quand il y a eu le choix
des anciens,
on a envoyé une lettre
à tous les frères
pour dire,
s'il y a une chose
qui vous paraît anormale,
vous pouvez encore
nous avertir
au cas où vous pensez
que ces frères
ne doivent pas être
nommés anciens.
C'était dans ce sens-là.
Dans ce sens.
Et donc,
c'est dans ce sens
que nous partons aussi
au niveau de l'église
Bonne Nouvelle.
Par la grâce de Dieu,
jusqu'à présent,
on n'a pas eu
une situation
où quelqu'un a été
indigne de cette confiance
parce que
si nous suivons
le processus biblique,
on ne va pas arriver
à une invalidation
de la personne.
Ce sont des fruits
que nous voyons.
C'est un témoignage
qui est apporté
par l'ensemble
et qui est confirmé.
Et donc,
pas trop ce problème.
Le troisième aspect
qui concernait
ces sept personnes
qui ont servi
de modèle
aussi plus tard
dans l'institution
des diacres,
c'était les qualités
qui étaient requises.
Donc,
dans les qualités
qui sont requises,
on va dire,
c'est pourquoi,
frère,
choisissez parmi vous
sept hommes réputés,
dignes de confiance,
dans ma version,
remplis du Saint-Esprit
et de sagesse.
Le choix qui était donné,
ce n'était pas un choix
de dire à un moment,
choisissez parmi vous
des personnes
qui ont une éloquence,
choisissez parmi vous
des personnes,
quelqu'un qui sait,
on va dire aujourd'hui,
qui sait manier
la feuille Excel.
Non.
Il va dire à un moment
des personnes
qui sont réputées,
dignes de confiance.
Et l'apôtre Paul
va même partir
sur cette vertu,
il va même partir sur ça
quand il va parler
intimité 3 du verset,
si Jordi,
tu peux nous chercher,
je vais te dire
quand elle se lit
intimité 3 du verset 8
au verset 12,
ce serait bien aussi
qu'on se replonge là-dessus.
On nous parle
qu'il faut qu'il soit
des personnes respectables
et qu'il y ait
une conduite exemplaire.
La chose qui est là,
et nous le rappelons
parce que aussi
cet enseignement général
aussi pour l'Église,
c'est que souvent
on a tendance
à se séparer
à idéaliser.
Aujourd'hui,
par exemple,
on va idéaliser
l'Église primitive
en disant que tout
était parfait
au niveau de l'Église primitive.
On a tendance
à idéaliser
des hommes
que nous allons lire
dans la Bible
en disant qu'ils étaient
parfaits.
Non, la chose
que Dieu nous rappelle,
ce sont des hommes faibles
qui travaillent
avec un Dieu grand,
comme disait Paul Washer.
Et là encore,
nous devons nous souvenir
à un moment
que les qualités
qui sont demandées,
ce sont des qualités
qui sont attendues
de tous membres
de l'Église.
Et là,
je parle particulièrement
pour les frères,
pour les hommes,
parce qu'il y a souvent
des frères qui vont dire
à un moment,
je n'aspire pas
à la charge d'évêque,
à une charge de diacre,
donc je pense
que je peux laisser
le fait que certains
progressent à d'autres.
Non,
ce n'est même pas comme ça.
Les progrès doivent être faits
par tout le monde.
par chacun de nous
qui devront être chacun
des personnes
qui recherchent le Seigneur.
Mais ce qui est dit
là-dedans,
donc Jordi,
si tu peux nous lire
le passage du verset 8,
du verset 8 à 12,
je crois que c'est le passage
qui concerne les diacres.
Les diacres aussi
doivent être honnêtes
et l'avis de la duplicité
et les grèves humains
d'un bien-cordi,
conservant le mystère
de la foi
dans une conscience pure.
Qu'on les découvre d'abord
et qu'ils exercent
ensuite leur mystère,
s'ils sont sans reproche.
Les femmes de même
doivent être honnêtes,
non-évitantes,
hommes, fidèles
en toutes choses.
Les diacres doivent être
maries d'une seule femme.
et dirigez bien leurs enfants
et leur propre maison.
Quand ceux qui remplissent
font la douleur
leur mystère,
s'en tirent un rang honorable
et une grande afférence
dans la foi en Dieu.
Amen.
Voilà, donc,
ce qui est attendu,
c'était d'être sans reproche
et d'inspirer le respect.
Une deuxième qualité requise,
c'était le fait
d'être rempli du Saint-Esprit.
Donc,
ce que nous devons nous rappeler,
c'est que chaque croyant
est rempli du Saint-Esprit.
Mais ce qu'il y a,
c'est que par rapport,
et c'est cet aspect,
c'est que ceux qui vont être
choisis ne sont pas
des paresseux spirituels.
C'était des personnes
qui travaillaient
pour que Christ grandisse
en eux.
Et le fait que Christ
grandisse en eux,
on voyait donc
plusieurs domaines
de leur vie
qui étaient touchés
par une maturité,
une soumission
au Saint-Esprit.
ça ne veut pas dire
que c'était
des personnes parfaites,
parce que c'est souvent
la dualité qu'il y a
de se dire,
un moment,
mais ces recommandations,
comment on peut répondre
à toutes ces recommandations ?
La vérité,
c'était des personnes
qui étaient proactives
à grandir dans la sainteté.
Et à cause
de cette proactivité,
il y avait des fruits
qui étaient évidents
pour tous.
Il y avait des fruits
qui se voyaient.
On parle aussi,
et cette troisième qualité
était une qualité essentielle
pour ce qu'ils avaient à faire,
qu'ils soient remplis
de sagesse.
Donc,
être rempli de l'esprit
va aussi toujours aller de pair
avec le fait
d'être rempli de sagesse.
Il fallait
que ce soit des personnes
qui aient
cette capacité
d'avoir une sagesse pratique,
ce qui était attendu
dans ce sens-là.
Et
sur ce dernier point,
c'est aussi encore
un encouragement
que,
comme on rappelait,
dans l'Église,
il n'y a pas
les pasteurs,
les diacres,
et puis des personnes
qui sont au milieu
qui ne font rien.
Nous tous,
nous sommes appelés
à quelque chose.
Nous tous,
nous sommes appelés
à cette proactivité,
à cette recherche de Dieu.
Les critères de choix
n'étaient pas
qu'ils aient établi
quatre ou cinq églises.
Les critères de choix
étaient de voir
le Saint-Esprit
travailler dans leur vie.
Et pour nous,
il n'y a pas
d'alternative.
C'est valable
pour tous les croyants
d'une assemblée.
Mais encore plus
dans le choix
des diacres.
Le quatrième point
qui est aussi intéressant
dans le choix
des sept,
c'était la répartition
du travail,
de la façon
dont ce travail
a été réparti.
Donc,
les apôtres
vont faire comprendre
qu'à un moment,
ils ne peuvent pas,
ils ne peuvent pas
par rapport
à la tâche
qu'ils ont déjà,
s'ils se soumettent
à la tâche,
ils prennent un fardeau
en plus de la tâche
qu'ils ont déjà
du ministère
de la parole
et de la prière,
leur ministère
allait être affecté.
Donc,
ce qu'ils sont
en train de dire,
c'est qu'il faut
une répartition
des tâches,
il faut quelqu'un,
un contrepoids
qui va les aider
dans plusieurs tâches.
Et voilà pourquoi
à un moment,
ils vont parler
du fait
d'établir ces personnes.
Donc,
aujourd'hui,
c'est vrai que
dans notre langage populaire,
avoir quelqu'un
qui sert
pour les tables,
c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas glorieux.
Il y a beaucoup
de personnes
qui n'aimeraient pas
un ministère dans l'Église
qui consiste à faire
des tâches,
peut-être qu'on va juger
basse,
que ça va servir aux tables,
que ça va être gérer
les toilettes
ou le nettoyage,
toutes des choses
comme ça.
Mais les apôtres,
même au travers
des qualifications
qu'ils sont en train
de choisir,
ils sont en train
de montrer
que c'était
un rôle important.
Être diacre,
ce n'est pas un rôle
subalterne,
c'est un rôle
qui est très important.
Dans le fait
qu'ils étaient en train
de choisir des diacres,
ils demandaient déjà
que ce soit des personnes
qui soient remplies
du Saint-Esprit,
que ce soit des personnes
qui soient remplies
de sagesse,
il fallait que ce soit
des personnes
qui les soulagent
afin que le ministère
de la parole
et de la prière
puissent continuer,
il fallait que ce soit
des personnes
qui travaillent
à l'unité de l'Église.
Il fallait que ce soit
des personnes
parce que le souci
qu'ils avaient là,
c'est que l'unité
de l'Église
était menacée.
Et donc,
les sept,
parce qu'aujourd'hui,
ce n'était pas encore
des diacres,
mais les sept
qui vont poser
ce modèle de diacre
étaient là pour aider,
pour amortir les problèmes.
Ils étaient là
pour amortir les chocs.
C'est-à-dire,
pour que les apôtres
n'aient pas apporté
certaines responsabilités
qui les éloigneraient
du but premier
que Dieu leur avait fixé,
ces sept hommes,
donc ces futurs diacres,
devaient être là
pour amortir le choc.
et on peut peut-être
considérer que ce problème
était,
on peut se dire,
c'était un problème alimentaire,
c'était un problème
de répartition de nourriture.
Non,
le problème
est beaucoup plus profond
que ça.
Et voilà pourquoi,
lorsque vous faites
des études
de la parole comme ça,
profitez aussi
pour pouvoir souvent
étudier le contexte
dans lequel
la chose est partagée.
Parce que,
par exemple,
ce qui va se passer
à un moment,
c'est qu'il y avait
des profondes différences,
de profonds différents
entre les Juifs palestiniens
et les Juifs
d'origine grecque
qui vivaient
dans le reste
de l'Empire romain.
Donc,
ce qui se passe,
c'est que c'était
des Juifs
qui étaient venus
pour la fête
de la Pentecôte
et ils n'avaient pas
prévu de rester là.
Ils n'avaient pas prévu.
Ils étaient venus
et ils étaient censés
repartir
dans les provinces.
Mais ce qui se passe,
c'est que Dieu
va travailler,
3000 vont se convertir,
ils vont être rajoutés
à l'Église
et donc,
finalement,
on va trouver
que les Juifs
hélénistiques,
donc les Juifs grecs,
vont se mélanger
aux Juifs palestiniens.
Et donc,
il y avait un problème
très sérieux
et ce problème
était en train
de menacer
l'unité de l'Église.
Comme je vous dis,
aujourd'hui,
on peut lire le verset 7
avec beaucoup de joie.
La parole de Dieu
se répondait toujours plus
mais ça n'aurait pas,
ça aurait pu
ne pas être
cette conclusion
parce que le problème
était assez important,
le problème
était quand même
assez sérieux.
et même
pour les personnes,
par exemple,
vous pouvez voir
même tous les témoignages,
vous allez retrouver
les témoignages
d'historiens
qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la Bible,
d'historiens séculiers
qui vont même parler
de ces différences-là
qui étaient quand même
assez profondes.
Et il y avait aussi,
donc,
au niveau des Hébreux,
il y avait cette compréhension
aussi de se dire
à un moment
que les Juifs grecs
et autres
n'étaient pas vraiment
des vrais Juifs,
c'était la définition,
du moment que tu sortais
de la Palestine
d'Israël,
tu n'étais plus
vraiment un vrai Juif
parce que Dieu
avait dit que la Terre
c'est en Palestine
et donc du moment
que tu sors,
ce n'est plus ça.
Donc,
on voit que c'est
un problème assez sérieux,
les apôtres étaient
confrontés quand même
à un problème
assez sérieux,
mais qu'est-ce que
les apôtres vont proposer
un moment ?
Au verset 5,
ils ont donc proposé
de prendre cette personne
remplie de l'Esprit,
digne de confiance.
Et au verset 5,
on nous dit
cette proposition
convainc à tous les disciples.
Ils élurent Étienne,
un homme plein de foi
et d'Esprit Saint,
ainsi que Philippe,
Procor,
Nicanor,
Timon,
Parmenas et Nicolas,
un païen originaire
d'Antioche
qui s'était converti
au judaïsme.
C'est important
de toujours voir
les détails
de ce que Dieu
nous enseigne.
Luc prend le nom
de ces personnes
et il est en train
de souligner
que si vous remarquez
un détail,
il n'y a aucun,
pratiquement,
dans les noms
que nous avons,
ce sont tous
des juifs grecs.
C'est-à-dire que
pour résoudre le problème,
aujourd'hui,
avec les cœurs humains,
si on devait résoudre
ce problème
de façon humaine,
on aurait dit
on va prendre
la moitié
des juifs palestiniens
et une moitié
des juifs grecs,
comme ça,
on va s'assurer
à un moment
que les intérêts
des juifs palestiniens
ne soient pas tournés.
Non.
Les apôtres,
vont comprendre
à un moment
que l'unité de l'Église
est beaucoup plus importante
et qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire ?
Ils vont demander
à ce que ce soit
sept juifs grecs
qui se chargent
de la répartition
des repas.
Donc,
il n'y avait pas
un souci
d'atteindre un quota
comme aujourd'hui
on serait dans
le politiquement correct
où il faut
un quota de minorité.
Ce n'était pas ça.
Mais ce qu'ils étaient
en train de montrer,
c'est que
le premier rôle
des diacres
était de se charger
de préserver
l'unité de l'Église.
Ils étaient là
comme des ondes
pour encaisser
les ondes de choc
pour permettre
justement que l'unité
de l'Église
ne soit pas touchée.
Et donc,
quand ils ont été choisis,
voilà pourquoi
une des premières caractéristiques,
là encore,
je parle aussi bien
pour ceux qui sont
dans ce rôle,
dans cet appel
qu'ils sont en train
d'étudier,
un appel de diacre
ou d'ancien,
c'est de comprendre
aussi ce rôle
d'abord que
un pasteur,
un diacre
va d'abord aimer
la paix
plus que l'attention
ou la riposte.
La première chose,
ça va toujours
une caractérisation
de la douceur.
Donc,
les sept
ont été choisis
non pas pour
accentuer le problème,
mais ils ont été choisis
justement pour permettre
justement que ce problème
soit réglé,
que ce différent
qui menaçait même
leur unité,
on va dire,
culturelle et autre,
que ce différent-là
soit réglé
par la paix.
Et je lis ce passage
de Marc Devers
qui explique un peu
le rôle qu'ils ont eu
un peu ce rôle premier
et ce rôle d'ancien.
Il dit à un moment
« Les diacres
s'occupent des besoins
matériels et financiers
de l'Église
et ils le font
de manière
à prévenir
les divisions,
à encourager
l'unité dans la parole
et à soutenir
la direction
des anciens. »
Le premier travail
des diacres,
ce sera d'abord
de s'assurer
que l'unité
de l'Église
est préservée.
Quand il va régler
un problème,
ce n'est pas pour apporter
davantage de division,
c'est pour s'assurer
à un moment
que l'unité
de l'Église
est préservée.
Sans ce service
pratique des diacres,
les anciens
ne seraient pas libres
pour vaquer à la prière
et au ministère
de la parole.
Les anciens
ont besoin de diacres
qui servent
de façon pratique
et les diacres
ont besoin
d'anciens
qui dirigent
spirituellement.
Donc,
ce rôle des diacres
était important
parce qu'à un moment,
même là,
aujourd'hui,
quand on parle
des tensions
qui vont surger,
je vous ai dit
un moment,
quand on lit
ces passages,
on a souvent tendance
à se focaliser
sur la beauté
de ce que Dieu faisait
dans l'Église primitive,
mais on a tendance
à souvent oublier
le passage dans le 1B
qui dit
des tensions surgées
entre les disciples juifs
de culture grecque
et ceux qui étaient nés
en Palestine.
On a souvent tendance
à oublier cet aspect-là.
Mais c'est un aspect
qui était là,
c'est un aspect
qui peut arriver.
La croissance
va nous amener aussi,
plus nous allons avoir
l'Église qui va grandir
et plus nous allons avoir,
nous devons être conscients
que ce genre de problème
peut arriver,
que des tensions surgissent,
que le fait
de toutes ces choses-là
vont surgir.
Et voilà pourquoi
il est nécessaire
à un moment,
arriver à un certain niveau,
il va être nécessaire
que Dieu permette
que des hommes
remplis de sagesse
puissent être là
pour gérer les problèmes,
pour amortir les chocs,
comme on va dire.
Donc, ce point des diacres
qui vont gérer le problème,
c'est le point,
on va dire,
le point central
dans la façon
d'aider les anciens.
Le rôle d'un diacre,
justement,
ce sera
que le diacre voit le problème
et le deuxième point
qui va le concerner
quand il voit un problème,
c'est qu'il voit
le fait qu'il faut préserver
l'unité de l'Église.
Ce n'est pas juste
qu'il voit un problème
et il se dit à un moment
qu'il a tellement envie
de le résoudre
ou bien qu'il se sente
tellement compétent
pour le résoudre.
Non, c'est parce qu'à un moment,
il comprend ce que ça représente
aux yeux de Dieu.
Il voit l'importance
de l'unité à préserver
et lorsqu'il voit
l'importance
de l'unité à préserver,
il va faire preuve
de créativité,
de sagesse
pour pouvoir résoudre
ce problème
et permettre justement
que le pasteur
ne porte pas ce problème.
Aujourd'hui,
pourquoi on a beaucoup,
dans beaucoup d'églises,
je parlais des pasteurs
qui sont en situation
de dépression et autres,
c'est parce que souvent,
on va regarder un moment
qu'ils n'ont personne
autour d'eux.
Ils sont seuls,
ils n'ont personne
qui va amortir les chocs.
Donc, à un moment,
ils doivent préparer
la prédication,
mais ils vont devoir régler
un problème
que deux personnes
ont eu entre elles.
Ils vont devoir préparer
la prédication,
mais à un moment,
ils vont devoir s'assurer
de voir les commandes
de la Sainte Seine
qui doivent arriver,
tout ça.
Et les personnes vont,
aujourd'hui,
pourquoi l'importance
des cours de membres,
quand nous parlons souvent
de l'importance
des cours de membres,
c'est pour rappeler
l'importance
que dans l'église,
nous sommes tous appelés
à nous engager.
Parce que souvent,
on va laisser,
par exemple,
le pasteur
dans beaucoup
de ses responsabilités
et on ne va pas vouloir
s'engager parce que
s'engager,
ça veut dire qu'on va
peut-être devoir
sacrifier certaines choses,
mais finalement,
ce pasteur se retrouve seul
à porter beaucoup de choses
et il fait une dépression
parce que derrière aussi,
il faut prendre soin
de sa famille
et s'il a des enfants,
il faut aussi pouvoir
avoir du temps
pour les enfants.
Mais la plupart
qui sont dans cette situation,
ce qui les conduit
même à cette dépression,
c'est qu'ils n'ont même
plus du temps
pour leurs épouses,
ils n'ont pas de temps
pour leurs enfants
parce qu'ils sont absorbés
par la tâche de l'Église.
Et s'ils osent se plaindre,
on va leur appeler
un moment qu'ils sont
le pasteur
et qu'ils sont payés pour ça.
Mais la vérité,
un moment,
voilà pourquoi
on voit un moment
que les apôtres
vont poser les conditions
mais les sept
vont être libres
de pouvoir agir.
C'est-à-dire que
dès que les apôtres
ont ces conditions,
que ces hommes
soient remplis de l'esprit,
soient réputés
dignes de confiance
et qu'ils aient
de la sagesse,
ils ont la liberté
maintenant
de pouvoir agir
pour pouvoir résoudre
ce problème
et aider les pasteurs,
les apôtres
sans que ce travail-là
soit en charge
des apôtres.
Et
le verset 7,
qu'est-ce que le verset 7
nous dit ?
La proposition va convenir.
La Bible nous dit
un moment au verset 6,
ils les présentaient,
donc l'assemblée a choisi
les sept,
ils les présentaient
aux apôtres
qui prièrent pour eux
et leur imposèrent
les mains.
La parole de Dieu
se répandait toujours plus.
Le nombre des disciples
s'accroissaient beaucoup
à Jérusalem
et même de nombreux prêtres
obéissaient à la foi.
Donc,
voilà la vérité
qui ressort aussi là derrière,
c'est que
au travers
le travail des diacres,
on a parlé d'un travail
qui est manuel,
qui peut souvent
paraître
inférieur
à des yeux humains,
mais c'est un travail
qui a de profondes
répercussions.
Ce qui va se passer,
c'est que grâce
au fait que ces hommes
ont pu être institués
et qu'ils ont pu travailler,
l'unité de l'Église
va être préservée.
Le verset 7 est possible,
la parole de Dieu
va continuer
à se répandre
toujours plus,
ce qui n'aurait pas
été le cas
si ce problème
avait persisté
et même conduit
à une division.
Donc,
le travail des diacres,
c'est un rappel
pour nous dire
à un moment
que même s'ils vont
se fixer
sur des besoins
physiques,
administratifs,
c'est un travail
qui a de profondes
implications spirituelles,
c'est un travail
qui a de profondes
implications
et il y a un lien
qui nous est montré
entre le fait
que la parole
puisse grandir
dans une Église
et le travail des diacres.
Et là,
on voit un moment
que ce travail-là
était en train
d'être fait.
Si les diacres
n'avaient pas
été institués,
on ne sait pas
ce qui se serait passé
pour les apôtres
qui auraient dû peut-être,
alors le but
de Satan
aurait été atteint,
la distraction
que Satan voulait créer
sera arrivée.
aujourd'hui,
il y a beaucoup
d'églises
qui sont tombées
parce qu'à un moment,
le pasteur
s'est détourné
de cette tâche première
qui était l'enseignement
de la parole,
la conduite
de la prière
et qui s'est totalement
engagée
dans les combats sociaux.
J'ai plusieurs exemples.
Aujourd'hui,
il y a un pasteur
qui est en prison
parce que c'est comme ça
qu'il a aussi commencé
d'abord.
À la fin,
ça l'a conduit à quoi ?
Le fait que ce ministère
social qu'il portait
avait plein de succès,
il s'est engagé
dans la politique,
à l'élection présidentielle
et maintenant,
il est en prison
pour, je ne sais pas,
peut-être de fausses accusations
de détournement de fonds,
toutes ces choses.
Mais la chose qu'il y a,
c'est que
si il est condamné
pour ça,
c'est qu'il n'a pas compris
la tâche première
qu'il avait.
S'il est condamné
parce qu'il a répondu
l'évangile
et qu'il a dit la vérité,
qu'il s'est tenu
sous cette vérité.
Comme notre frère David
nous parlait
des frères en Hollande
face aux nazis,
nous allons trouver
qu'il y a un sens.
Mais là,
il s'est totalement écarté
et ça a été autre chose.
Donc,
beaucoup de pasteurs,
à un moment,
quand ils vont plonger
dans ça,
ou ils vont abandonner
cette progression
de la parole,
vont se retrouver
dans des situations
qui n'honorent pas Dieu.
Donc,
on voit le travail
des diacres
qui a un lien
avec la progression
de la parole,
le fait que les diacres
aient pu soulager
les apôtres,
les apôtres ont pu
se consacrer
sur le fait
de continuer
à prendre soin
de l'Église
parce que l'Église
était en pleine croissance
donc ça veut dire
que les apôtres
n'avaient pas de repos,
ils n'avaient pas
une minute pour eux
et c'est pour ça
que je dois aussi
encore rappeler
que souvent,
certaines personnes
ont eu tendance
à considérer
que les apôtres
étaient un peu
du mépris
dans le fait
de ne pas traiter
ce problème
mais c'est parce
qu'il y avait
un problème encore
plus urgent
qui était le gagnement
des âmes.
Il y avait des âmes
qui étaient sauvées,
qui étaient ajoutées
et qui demandaient
un engagement
constant des apôtres
et donc il y avait
ce besoin
que les diacres
travaillent dans ce sens
mais nous voyons,
là où nous voyons
les implications,
regardons l'exemple
de ces diacres
où la portée
a été encore
plus grande que ça.
Étienne,
aujourd'hui,
quand on regarde
la qualification
qu'on a pour certains diacres,
il n'y a pas beaucoup
de diacres
qui pourraient faire
une prédication,
un message
comme Étienne l'a fait
devant les responsables
religieux,
de cette connaissance
de Dieu qu'il avait,
de ce qu'il a dit
avant d'être lapidé.
Regardons Philippe,
c'est ce même Philippe
qui a été choisi,
qui va être au contact
de l'Eunuque éthiopien,
qui va évangéliser
l'Eunuque éthiopien
et qu'on va désigner
comme Philippe l'évangéliste,
pas comme Philippe le diacre
mais comme Philippe l'évangéliste.
Donc c'est pour comprendre
cette portée qu'il y a,
de comprendre aussi
cette importance,
cette emphase
qui est mise
dans le contenu,
dans le contenu spirituel
qu'un diacre doit avoir.
Dans cette recherche de Dieu,
le fait que ce soit
quelqu'un qui doit être
rempli de l'esprit,
qui doit être proactif
à chercher le Seigneur
et à servir les autres.
Et on voit cet exemple
au travers d'Étienne
et au travers de Philippe.
Donc,
dans cette conclusion
que je ne vais pas apporter,
c'est que c'est une vision
glorieuse des diacres
dont nous devons nous souvenir.
Dans ce passage,
il y a encore...
Oui, parce que là...
D'accord.
Donc, ce qu'on peut conclure,
cette conclusion que je...
le verset 7
nous permet la bonne conclusion.
La parole de Dieu
se répondait toujours plus.
Après l'institution
de ses frères,
la croissance a pu continuer.
Et donc,
nous devons,
en conclusion,
pour comprendre,
c'est que...
Nous devons comprendre
que ce n'est pas un ministère...
Ce n'est pas un ministère...
Nous devons prendre conscience
que c'est un ministère
qui demande...
qui est solennel aussi.
Ce n'est pas un ministère
à prendre à la légère.
Quand on parle
d'hommes remplis de l'esprit,
d'hommes dignes de confiance
et des hommes sages,
ça veut dire
qu'il y a des prérequis
qui demandent
à ce que nous soyons sérieux
dans la façon
dont nous sommes en train
de rechercher le Seigneur.
Mais,
ce que nous devons aussi comprendre,
c'est que nous ne devons pas
nous couper
parce que certains vont dire
à un moment,
je trouve que c'est trop...
c'est trop de prérequis
et je préfère rester dans mon coin.
Ce n'est pas comme ça
que ça marche.
L'appel de Dieu,
chaque fois que des hommes
ont été appelés,
nous devons être conscients
qu'il n'y avait aucun homme
qui était en train
de se tourner les pouces,
de regarder le ciel,
qui était assis sur la pelouse
et qui regardait le ciel.
Non.
Chaque fois que vous voyez
dans la Bible
des hommes qui ont été appelés,
on les voit toujours
en activité.
Et Dieu est en train
de nous rappeler
à un moment
que pour nous,
l'activité est nécessaire
et nous devons comprendre
cet engagement.
et donc,
c'était le point,
le point de choix,
le point de choix
de ces hommes
et le point de choix
aujourd'hui
dans le choix des diacres,
c'est de voir des personnes
qui sont actives
et encourageantes
dans la recherche du Seigneur.
Et ce sont des personnes
qui vont aider les anciens.
Là, dans le cadre
de ce que nous avons lu
dans l'acte 6,
ils aidaient les apôtres.
Mais aujourd'hui,
dans notre temps,
ce sont des personnes
qui vont aider le pasteur
pour lui permettre
de se consacrer
à la tâche première
que Dieu lui a donnée
qui est l'enseignement
de la parole
et de la prière.
Et le travail du diacre
sera de s'assurer
à un moment
que le pasteur
ne soit pas en train
de perdre du temps
en dehors de ces tâches-là.
Si donc,
à un moment,
vous voyez votre pasteur
qui est en train...
Ça peut arriver au début
de l'église,
c'est tout à fait normal.
Mais si à un moment,
on avance dans le temps
et que c'est toujours
le pasteur
qui est en train
de s'occuper
de monter la vidéo,
qui est en train
de s'occuper
de faire des tâches
à gauche, à droite,
c'est que l'église...
Et quand vous avez déjà
une église
de plus d'une dizaine
de personnes,
c'est que les personnes
n'ont pas compris
ce que Dieu attend de nous.
Mais chaque fois,
nous devons,
dans cette évaluation,
c'est de nous dire
comment je suis en train
d'aider le pasteur
ou d'aider les anciens
de l'église.
Comment je suis en train
d'apporter ma pierre.
Et là-dessus,
pour ceux qui sont en train
de réfléchir à cet appel
de diacre,
c'est de réfléchir aussi
à comment je vois un problème,
comment je vois un moment
que l'unité de l'église
ou bien la santé de l'église
peut être menacée
et comment je peux apporter
une solution à ce problème.
Et souvent,
ceux qui apportent
la solution à ce problème,
souvent ceux qui vont
voir le problème,
ce sont même ceux
qui sont les plus aptes
à pouvoir apporter
la solution
et à régler le cas.
Donc ça,
je le disais pour ceux
qui seraient des volontaires
là-dessus.
Gloire à Dieu.
Donc,
voilà ce que nous pouvions dire
ce soir
dans la Genèse des Diacres.
Donc,
nous voyons au moment
que le passage d'Acte VI
est un passage important
parce qu'il va poser
les bases
pour comprendre plus tard
comment l'église
va instituer les diacres,
va instituer
et choisir
les diacres.
Donc,
c'était un passage
central dans ce sens-là.
Je vais prier
puis on va,
s'il y a des questions,
je pense qu'à un moment
on aura
le droit de couper,
mais...
Seigneur,
nous te remercions
pour ce moment,
pour ta parole
parce que
tu es
merveilleux
dans toutes les voies,
dans toutes tes voies,
Seigneur.
Te bénissons
parce que
nous voyons
cet exemple
de l'église
qui était en train
de croître
malgré la persécution
de l'église
qui était en train
de croître
malgré
les faux croyants
qui pouvaient
s'immiscer
au milieu d'elle,
l'église
qui était en train
de croître
malgré certains problèmes
qui pouvaient surgir.
Nous te remercions
Seigneur
parce que
nous voyons
cet exemple
biblique
où malgré
les plans
de Satan
de distraire,
de détourner
les apôtres
de leur mission
première,
tu leur as donné
d'avoir cette sagesse
de tenir ferme
sur ce que
tu leur avais donné
et d'impliquer
l'assemblée
dans le choix
de cet homme sage
qui devrait
régler ses problèmes.
Merci Seigneur
parce que
ce n'était pas
un problème léger,
c'était quelque chose
de profond
mais tu as permis
que ces hommes sages
puissent le résoudre
et que la parole
puisse continuer
de progresser.
Oui Seigneur
c'est une leçon
pour nous aujourd'hui
aussi de comprendre
Seigneur
que nous avons besoin
dans notre église
d'hommes sages
qui vont se lever
pour aider
les anciens,
pour aider les pasteurs,
pour alléger
considérablement
le travail des pasteurs
afin que ceux-ci
puissent se consacrer
entièrement
à l'enseignement
de la parole,
à la prière.
Nous te remercions
Seigneur
pour cela
et nous prions
pour que ce soit
une réalité
qui revienne
dans l'église
et nous voyons
les choix
de ces hommes
qui n'ont pas été faits
sur des choix humains
à cause
d'une position sociale,
de qualité humaine
mais des choix
qui ont été faits
à cause
de Christ
qui était visible
dans la vie
de ces personnes.
Alors Seigneur
nous prions
pour que nous n'ayons
pas des standards
plus bas que cela.
Nous prions
pour que nos standards
soient semblables
à ceux de Acte 6
dans le choix
des diacres
que nous ayons
cette conscience
pour ceux
qui sont appelés
à cela
qui soient
dans cet examen
et qui n'aient pas peur
Seigneur
d'être proactifs
à ce que Christ
grandisse en eux
tandis qu'ils diminuent
Seigneur.
Nous te remercions
Seigneur
parce que
c'est une leçon
pour nous
de voir que
malgré les différences
culturelles
l'Église
n'a pas été divisée
mais l'Église
a choisi
de s'appuyer
sur la parole
et les apôtres
ont même choisi
de faire confiance
à des frères
qui étaient
d'origine grecque
pour gérer
le problème
et cette confiance
totale
c'est ce désir
de préserver
l'unité
qui doit toujours
remplir nos cœurs
Seigneur.
Alors nous prions
pour les hommes
qui ont ce désir
de préserver l'unité
nous prions
pour ces hommes
qui ont ce désir
de travailler
à ce que
tu grandisses en eux
des hommes réputés
dignes de confiance
remplis du Saint-Esprit
et de sagesse
et nous te remercions
Seigneur pour cela
au nom de
Saint-Jésus-Christ
Amen
Je ne sais pas
si
peut-être
une ou deux questions
si vous avez
par rapport
à ce qui a été dit
Alors
littéralement
c'est assez simple
c'est que
dans la situation
de l'église
on se retrouvait
avec des frères
qui étaient polygames
donc certains
étaient polygames
mais là encore
c'est important
pour nous
de nous souvenir
que quand nous faisons
nos choix
que nous voulons
comprendre
une définition
de comment nous
devons définir
nos choix de vie
c'est de toujours
avoir cette considération
non pas pour
on va dire
on doit toujours
aller dans le sens
de la volonté parfaite
de Dieu
qu'est-ce que Dieu
a d'abord donné
en premier
parce que souvent
certaines personnes
vont souvent choisir
par exemple
certains vont justifier
Dieu va nous parler
quand je parle par exemple
dans la préparation
au mariage
avec des saints
je vais leur rappeler
un moment
que le divorce
n'est pas une option
il n'y a même pas
à se dire
un moment
mais si
un jour on divorcait
parce que dans la compréhension
du mariage
selon Dieu
le divorce
n'est même pas une option
et du moment
où il y a deux croyants
les deux croyants
vont toujours
devoir s'assurer
un moment
de comprendre
que c'est une alliance
qui est établie
et c'est une alliance
qu'ils doivent respecter
tant qu'ils seront
ici bas
jusqu'au bout
donc le divorce
ne sera même pas
imaginable
et là ce que Dieu
va faire
c'est même de préserver
sa volonté première
dans ce sens
où il va donc rappeler
il y avait des situations
où il y avait des frères
qui avaient plusieurs épouses
et ça rejoignait
un peu la situation
où le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
avait dit à un moment
à cause de l'endurcissement
du cœur
il nous arrive un moment
de pouvoir étendre
toutes ces choses
d'aller au-delà
de ce que Dieu a recommandé
et comme Dieu permettait
on va dire un peu
cette petite
on va dire
cette petite fenêtre
cette petite lucarne
certains vont pouvoir
mais c'est vraiment
une exhortation
chaque fois
ne cherchons pas
à aller dans le sens
de la petite lucarne
qui a été donnée
à cause de l'endurcissement
des cœurs
notre priorité doit toujours
d'obéir à ce qui a été donné
en premier
par rapport à la parole de Dieu
donc dans ce sens
les apôtres vont être clairs
en rappelant un moment
que
aussi bien pour l'ancien
que pour le diacre
il faut qu'il soit mari
d'une seule femme
et donc
on ne pouvait pas trouver
dans l'église
quelqu'un qui soit ancien
et qui soit polygame
et même dans le choix
de diacre aussi
d'autres questions
c'était clair
si c'était
je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres questions
on va
on va arrêter là
et
oui
mon encouragement aussi
c'est vraiment
alors
on sait que ce n'est pas évident
on sait qu'on enregistre aussi
mais l'encouragement
c'est vraiment
que toute l'église
vous voyez
même dans le processus
quand on lit acte 6
on voit toute l'implication
de l'église
dans cette compréhension
de cela
donc c'est aussi important
que dans
cette phase
que nous sommes en train
de traverser
l'encouragement
c'est que vraiment
toute l'église soit impliquée
si tu n'as pas pu être là
en soirée
assure-toi
de regarder
la vidéo
l'enregistrement
quand c'est fait
parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est très important
et ça nous permet
de rétablir
le modèle biblique
ce que nous sommes en train
de faire
c'est aussi
que ce soit une portée
pour l'église
notre encouragement aussi
c'est que l'église
puisse revenir
à ses critères de choix
de diacre ou d'ancien
aujourd'hui
dans beaucoup d'églises
même des églises
en bonne santé
quand on choisit un diacre
on ne le choisit pas
en fonction des critères bibliques
on va le choisir
en fonction du nombre
de personnes
qu'il a pu emmener à Christ
même s'il a un caractère
détestable
donc beaucoup de choix
du moment
qui manient bien
la feuille
Excel
comme on a dit
ça va être des choix
mais ce n'est pas ce que Dieu
nous montre
et l'encouragement
pour ceux qui sont
dans cet appel
de diacre ou d'ancien
c'est de voir aussi
comment Dieu met l'emphase
sur l'importance du caractère
l'importance du caractère
la douceur
la patience
l'amour
les apôtres ont témoigné ça
ils auraient pu régler ça autrement
mais la patience
la douceur
qu'ils ont montré
ont permis aussi
que l'église aille
dans ce sens plus tard
voilà
Amen